hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Emily wants to play too
and happy Halloween everybody we're
gonna be playing some scary games this
Halloween and it all starts with Emily
wants to play too
so I it's been a long time since I
played Emily wants to play one and thank
you everybody so much for the patience
with me getting back to scary games and
games in general hello hi hello
everybody oh that was a crazy party
I'm exhausted here I've also got some
other games lined up after this because
this is only the demo for this game hi
hello we're gonna get right into this
don't even worry you me I'm so sleepy
and I'm so glad I have these lovely
paintings right by my room here what the
hell is that popping out of the pot over
there oh whatever it doesn't matter
oh that's not that's not disconcerting
at all especially the fact that it's at
the end of a hallway oh jeez oh I get it
I threw a crazy party last night I'm the
fool that invited everybody over to my
abode oh I'm the idiot oh there's a
power box over there I need to go
upstairs to bed am I just narrating this
to myself oh it's it's uh oh oh I'm
upstairs now alright okay thank you oh
good I got a picture of grandma on my
house oh boy I sure do love my creepy
art ah okay heard that hello guys yes
welcome happy Halloween happy Halloween
indeed is this my bedroom ah I stumbled
over a styrofoam tray for a from tray
the scariest possible thing I could have
possibly stumbled over alright let's go
over here I guess yeesh
yeesh oh okay alright then I'm just
gonna slowly try to meander my way over
this way and hopefully nothing terrible
will happen to me one second I had to
make sure that everything isn't
absolutely exploding everywhere
I gotta all right cool yeah everything's
good right
good what I don't know what you're
talking about for Halloween this year
ah hey I decided to go as a 2012 mark
Blair you know you know how it is you
know how it do ooh
that's spooky all right hang on I got it
I got it I got it I gotta change one
thing and then then then we'll be good
hey one second there okay let's try that
all right back into it hopefully nothing
explodes like crazy hello I really need
to go to bed well which way is my bed
which was supposed to be my bed you know
this is my bed oh good I got I saved the
creepiest part of all for my room ah
home sweet home
wonderful wonderful ah my bad let me lay
my head down to rest in my bed and see
what the hell's going on here yeah
where's the beard I don't know I sucked
it back into my face as hard as I could
and that's that's where my beard went
okay yeah where's my alarm set for 3:00
a.m. the alarm clock is so annoying yeah
okay how am i oh there we go
you need a shower before I go to work
why do I go to work at 3:00 a.m. why is
that a thing that happens what in the
world is happening yet I have no idea
hey I got changed I got changed one more
thing because I just I just forgot well
is is the video lagging at all because I
see that my CPU is spiking up to like
100% which isn't supposed to be
happening at all
why is this goddamn game take up so much
resources but is everything looking ok
in the video here because I'm not on my
main computer I'm on my on my like cheap
office computer at all everything look
good
a little I have no lag let's see not
really lagging not lagging I have no
idea
yes it's lagging no it's fine it looks
good great well you guys are just a
bunch of conflicting information that I
don't think is help in this scenario
yeah looks good alright I'm gonna
continue until you guys tell me
otherwise
chica don't move over there it's very
scary
alright yeah hello okay what's going on
over here
hello tiny box Tim you've changed and I
don't like it
hello what's gonna pop out of the box
what's gonna pop out of the box okay
great old mommy just gonna shower up and
get naked next to that horrifying box
Yee ah good that's that's no good the
waters kind of gross but I'm using a lot
of soap that always helps those
alleviates my problems oh wait I know
what I know I know what's what's causing
the problem here hang on I've got
another game that was loaded up and
ready to go hand see if that helps a
little bit all right
ah excellent I've showered and the box
is gone great good
good stuff happening good Greg gosh gosh
golly gosh great okay
all righty then mm-hmm Oh my old friend
Oh the clown from it how are you doing I
love your big grabby hands I don't
remember how you work but I don't like
you at all
okay I'm gonna back away slowly out of
this room than ever all right all righty
then
don't go in there huh okay i'ma go in
there now where did I put my car keys
hello hi friend
grandpa so you are you doing this the
slender man just sitting in a rocking
chair in my house where did I put my car
keys my number-one priority after
everything that's gone wrong here II run
I don't know about that
running seems like a silly option now
why would I do that are you guys out of
your gourds if you need a jump-scare
list
there ain't no jump-scare list when
you're doing it live let her in some
dark apply our level [ __ ] that's some
Damien and Celine and everyone knows
what happened with that oh those eyes
are gonna open all those those eyes are
gonna open yeah okay well hey hi how's
it going
hey no thank you I don't like that we're
done now where did I put my car keys
where to Humpty diddly doo deee daaah
did i put my car keys
okay all right ding dong ding dong ding
dong you know I'm gonna go with a big
hard no on that one I'm gonna nope away
from this situation why do I keep
stepping over things and it keeps
throwing me everywhere all right turn
that on stop doing that don't do that
this is my house not your house you
don't get to goof me in my own house
now where did I put my car keys okay no
no no I'm not okay with that one I don't
know where I am and I don't know where
I'm going it's pitch blackness what is
happening we're oh boy okay that's not
good I don't like you I remember that
noise and that noise was nothing but bad
oh hello you still get in here you're
still good buddy can I turn this on oh
gone
what a wonderful precarious situation
I've put myself in this is my live
streaming room hi I recognize it by all
the art on the walls
well can't play my guitar can I sing you
a song play a ditty here ye okay why do
you think you turning out the lights on
me okay there was no need for that
I like oh my god there's no need to slam
doors I like to keep them open for many
many routes of escape I don't like that
either I don't like that at all Oh
flashlight
well ain't that ain't that Hey oh look
at that
Hey is that my car keys oh there's my
car keys Wow okay all right then well
good for me I said what oh of course the
most important thing to do when demons
are infesting your house go wash the
Frick frack and dick docking dishes how
about you take your dishes and you shove
them up your stupid butthole
how about that how about that how about
you do a whole lot of that huh how about
you do that
this game has a time limit I don't know
I want to take my time you take your
time limit and you shove up your time
limiting what whole oh I don't care all
right here we go I'm gonna wash the
dishes apparently this is what I'm gonna
do
apparently lalalala oh yeah priority
number one okay great cool I'm washing
the dishes like a responsible adult cuz
that's what I am a responsible adult
that somehow these pictures are a
nightmare these are the scariest dishes
I've ever seen oh my god
these goddamn dishes and then it's a
spoofer you say time with butthole I
don't remember saying oh my god
why did that happen why did that happen
what why did that happen why was that
okay well that's a thing so what am i I
wanna I don't wanna I don't wanna
why why did any of that happen I don't
trust anything ever in my life I trust
nothing the alarm clock is - all okay I
got go through this goddamn time loop
again huh huh oh is that what I gotta do
huh good okay
dumb alarm stupid alarm alarming me -
alarm things and is it possible to jump
out the window I don't know but I'd like
to try okay all right so I'm a brave boy
see it's different when it's live cuz
then you guys are experiencing at the
same time as me yeah oh yeah this is
live why don't do that do I gotta take a
shower I'm gonna take a shower I guess
cuz apparently I really did die oh it's
disgusting water ah soupy water ah the
water oh no and then I got to do it I
got it I gotta wash the the terrifying
things Oh God its waters kind of gross
indeed it is oh yeah okay so I'm gonna
assume that what you guys said about
there being a time limit was 100% true
and I gotta get my get my butt out that
or with more wolf as some discussing
water okay so how do I run is there a
way to run oh that's how you run okay I
got it whoo oh my keys are not oh no how
about no that's good no about they go -
no no stop no don't do that
we do a lot of not that hello squeaks
crunk
oh you're gone now apparently okay
that's how we're gonna play this game
can i well I didn't know I could pick
that up can I pick up yes okay if I take
this sword and stabbed it in my eye hole
I'll be fine this is how we're gonna
survive this everybody this is how we're
gonna survive good go all right
continuing on all right that's fine hey
you [ __ ] bucko get out of my face
where'd I put my keys no really put
anything in this godforsaken hellhole ya
know like that nope you can [ __ ] right
off you can die in a hole oh yeah I
gotta do the dishes I forgot about that
it's okay I stabbed katanas in my
eyeball all the time don't worry about
that that's totally fine mm oh god it's
not the scary dishes again oh god oh god
all right
oh thank you for the advice stay away
from the clown ah I didn't ever thunk
that I've never funcle' that in my life
oh there's no way I could funcle' up
don't do that where'd I put my goddamn
car keys but I put my goddamn car keys
oh there's more house I I didn't know I
had more house I don't know where my car
keys are all right wait hey bye Emily
Babli Emily now Emily
Emily don't do that oh that's a lot of
clocks on the wall
okay I'm gonna find it I'm gonna go find
it yes
munch spoop the keys are in the bathroom
you guys saw the keys huh that's so
helpful
you guys are so helpful to me being here
with me in the spoop zone tonight oh
they are you guys weren't oh you guys
are so helpful there's my car I just
gotta get the hell out of here right I
just gotta get the hell out of here I
could leave for work now I'm gonna do
that I would do exactly that here I go
leaving for work running his fancies
again not looking behind me no nope nope
nope nope nope that dumb fuse box oh ha
ha ha I don't like it yeah I don't like
it I don't like a dumb fuse box I got a
dumb fuse box
I knew it everything's fine
everything is a-okay everything is fine
did I do it did I done did did I done
diddle it correct okay
okay all right well that's a thing that
happened to me turn that off okay guy go
run oh I don't like that okay shut up
go shower its demons Jim its demons its
demons Jim okay mark look at the
surroundings oh thank you thank you for
that look at the surroundings you said
that's all I gotta do who didn't own a
even funk that Oh God okay here we go
alright so I gotta find the keys
wherever the hell those are I don't know
where they are let me check my where did
I put my keys I don't know in my bedroom
someone nope no 'pls noble opal all
right well that's creepy but hey well
your creepiness is gonna be beaten by my
brash nature okay that's what I have to
say about you and you to you is that a
key no that's a fork I thought that was
a key turned out to be a fork let's do
these scary dishes first okay
you gotta stay low
I can't stay low in this game because
there's no way to stay low staying low
is not an option
embrace the boob that's not even advice
I don't shutting off the electricity
scares me ok then why did I do that I
don't want any of that no no don't do
don't do the double no don't don't no no
sir
okay just cry in the corner it's best
for all of us you know I'm inclined to
agree with you look oddly I'm inclined
to agree with you hey I work at Timmy
thumb's fast sandwiches all right
that's funny nope all right let's grab
the shower how many times do I need to
grab this disgusting shower how many
times oh you're welcome yeah see
no jump-scare list to hide behind you
just gotta experience it live and use a
lot of soap geez yeah I will do it I
will do a playthrough of evil within -
that's the thing I want to do with like
these these live streams like I wanna I
want to do everything that I was doing
before but in a live atmosphere so that
I can be with you guys when this is
happening it's just it's a bit more fun
like to know that you guys are here and
also I won't get so lost because you're
a girl you guys will be like the keys
the keys you idiot Oh
get the keys they're right there even
though I'll probably no no no you know
no I'm nope
ah the keys excellent there's my car
keys ah ha ha scary dishes time and then
I got to find the key card and then I
got to get out of here I think that's
what I'm getting but I have no idea if
that's actually gonna happen I have no
idea read some books okay all right I
check the book covers okay I'll get your
guys I'll get towards these dishes
they're just so scary and I gotta wash
um I'm just my fear of these dishes are
so high
hey yeah yeah yeah she's coming after me
I know she's coming after me I'm well
aware of what she's coming after and how
me that is that she is the me okay I can
leave for work now all right book covers
checking them checking them these are
the videogame physics Matthew Patrick
this game theory for the psychology of
reacting the
finebros first samurai okay
PewDiePie this book loves you too wish
me
am i in here why do I have so many
laptops this is too close to home all
right
where's all my porn stash all right that
was good no okay better fix it before I
leave nope not dealing with that there
we go
okay got it now I gotta go over here
nope not gonna look at that okay you
leave for working out nope no I'm gonna
do that key card required don't like
that oh don't do that
god dammit dammit I shouldn't leave yet
but I was just doing the thing oh don't
do that
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay let's try this again
I got forgot the flashlight where is the
flashlight flashlight not here
flash Oh their flashlights chica don't
move over there chicas moving in her bed
and it's not okay it's not okay oh I
know my mic speaking I'm aware of that
it's really nothing I can do about that
at this juncture in time kind of when I
scream it gets real loud in here uh but
I'm trying to turn it down
ah yah yah yah yah okay it's fine it's
fine just do this get the dishes done
the keys turn the fuse on check the door
and then I'll get to whatever the next
objective is whatever that may be going
as fast as I can ladies and gentlemen
and fast as I can
hello hello anybody in here is that my
lucky flannel my lucky flannel right
there yeah probably
there probably it probably is probably
clowns not there but Oh clown is there
okay there's my car keys
that's no that's a big no on that one
all right
hi yah yah yah yah hey I won saying uh
yah yah yah yah yah yah okay then we got
to get the keys then we got to get out
of here then we gotta go on everything
good do what we got to do and then we're
out here hey okay
all right cool again turn around turn
around that's a terrible idea
you're terrible don't do that all right
here we go
oh no the damn fuse box Oh No
Oh doh swap I don't know having how do I
get around how do I get around how do I
get around that how do I get around that
I have no idea
do I gotta like flip it on and off again
like flip the power on and off probably
what I gotta do I don't know I don't
know I don't know don't know shut up the
clocks wait till she leaves ah keep
staring at her that makes sense okay
that makes sense that makes sense okay
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do that one
I got that this time I got it you guys
believe in me cuz I do I believe in me
and the me that I am oh what is this
game this is Emily wants to play too and
it's spooky happy Halloween everybody
too many showers is that even possible
I'm just so dirty I just gotta clean
myself up did I miss the keys are the
keys over there again no where are my
keys
who took my keys where's my keys you
guys got my keys anybody seen my keys
stop looking around I don't wanna okay
all right this time we got her beat if
she shows up I know how to
eat her butt punching her repeatedly in
the face over and over again punch oh
hello everybody from school I'm glad
you're at school watching this stream
that's a good use of your time that's a
good use of your time
these matches are so scary I can't
believe how scary these dishes just flip
her off yeah that's right give her one
of these give her an old these we got it
underway
it's haven't found my keys and where did
I put my car keys
excellent question wait is that them
that is them
well almost miss that uh don't do that
do not I can leave for work now Oh Boosh
Oh No
that dumb fuse box alrighty then okay
bring it on
well I don't know how to beat you I
don't know how to beat you I don't know
okay I was not ready for that
you don't stare at that one apparently
who'd have even funcle' bit no not
having that no not having that not
having it not having it I'm not having
it I've had it up to here with it why is
that doll in my closet did I not notice
that doll in my closet another shower
everybody another shower oh great okay
everybody climb in the shower with me
we're all gonna shower together together
ah oh yeah yeah yay Frick frack a dick a
deck
mark the clocks I get it the clocks I
can't even get to the clocks yet I can't
get past them I gotta get to the clocks
I will get to them
I gotta get to him first you don't
understand I'm trying my best and my
best just ain't good enough my just my
best it's just like not sufficient
enough of the best bet it is hello from
Spain this alright here we go one more
time into the parang okay I don't like
any of you all keys perfect there's my
car keys here's the nightmare dishes is
the doll your sex doll I don't think Oh
think that dolls my sex doll and if this
person in this game if that is the way
that it is oh we got a lot more to be
scared about that way originally funked
everybody everybody everybody calm down
everybody calm down you're being a
little you're being a little crazy I
appreciate it
a Boosh better fix it before I leave why
so I can waste power alright who's there
no one all right let's go let's go let's
go let's go let's go let's go look no
again why that's not fair okay clocks
clocks right clocks okay looking at the
clocks five
oh no no see I wasn't crazy I wasn't
crazy okay someone said use the pictures
I don't wanna go near those kooky scary
skeleton spine okay we got this though
we got this it's all good it's all good
guys it's all good we got this if you
think that we don't got this you are
wrong and we got this so hard
ha ha all right whose idea is that whose
idea is it to use the paintings or whose
idea is it to any of this whose idea is
it to anything here whose idea is that
to fix the fuse before you leave whose
idea is it to take a nice relaxing
shower in the most disgusting water
imaginable I don't know whose idea it is
it's not mine and I don't want nothing
to do with it I should wash the dishes
before I go indeed I should indeed I
should
okay we got it we got this we got this
everything's good everything's yeah we
got this we got this we got this we got
chicken stop moving
don't why is it there's a lot of moaning
happening behind me originally I thought
it was chica but it may not be okay use
the painting using it using it as hard
as I can use odo the dab fuse it broke
right no no I'm not going look what do I
do you what do I do
okay all right guys give me a breakdown
give me a breakdown of give me a
breakdown I get that the doll you stare
at I get the the the clown I forget what
the clown is but I think the little like
gangster doll you have to you have to
like turn the light back on before it
gets you because that's like from the
first game
the tall guy what do you do what do you
do you have to take him out to dinner
that doesn't help anybody I'm not gonna
take about today I don't care how dapper
he is in his suit you know that guy's
looking a little grey his skid turns
gray you know I think it's dark I will
play the evil within to it there's a
clown no movement okay clown no movement
that's right found no woman jump out the
window that doesn't show him chica these
don't not helping at all
not helping give him a kiss no I just
wanna give him a kiss don't look at him
that's what I did I didn't look at him
I swear I give him the sword I know send
Jim after him this is not helping he's
handsome I don't care how handsome is
okay all right
now where did I put my car keys all
right let's see show them the pictures B
to blow these you banged a horse that
that is not anything to do is what's
happening here and frankly I'm just
concerned
turn the lights close a door behind him
I suppose that would help now that's
actually tangible tangible help there I
think that's good I gotta do my dishes
reset the fuse box that might be good
that might be good okay I'll try the
fuse box and if that doesn't work scream
Adam Stoneham nope punch him in the ass
boop his snoot I don't I don't think any
of these are helpful ideas and I think
you guys are all just absolutely not not
giving this you're all here I think you
guys are just goofing me pretty hard
okay nope don't do that okay
so falcon punch him nope no think so
there's nothing to be done with the
books I think that's don't like that all
right it's fine it's fine
nope no oh okay
we're fine
damnit
show him the eight pages nothing so Oh
God turn up ah
that was not the same guy that was not
the same guy that was not the handsome
man that I thought was gonna be there
that was someone very different that was
extremely different that was not that
was not that was not what I was that's
not what I thought it was gonna be those
that was the opposite of give him a
smooch no no fart fart on his balls I'm
gonna assume 100% that that's not not
the right strategy I I think I think
that's pretty much pretty much
guaranteed not the correct strategy
there if I had to guess if I had to
think about it real hard like no not
gonna do that
hug him no no I've been doing that
hugging him has been like my number one
strategy and frankly it's terrible
advice throwing through all right
lick his face give him a cigarette no
when I kick him in the nuts now that
actually actually might do it okay key
card is behind the cabinet someone said
that's the clown that is not the clown
the clown isn't the clown is like much
shorter than that from what I remember
if that's the clown then I live no no no
no stop showering and doing the dishes
okay you know what that's good advice
I'm gonna do that alright so something
about cabinet ooh whoa whoa whoa whoa I
shouldn't run with these but I got him
okay ah new developments okay
choose wisely and fail why did that
ding-dong she's wisely or fail oh okay
ah interesting enlightened quotes you
must see the answer to know the answer
is there some kind of puzzle here with
these paintings I don't know there's the
keys though
okay we're onto something here more than
just our scares hello sir
all right so what do we got going on
oh-ho yes please
Oh another book no notebook nothing okay
so there's a lot more in this place to
use than I originally suspected and if I
can use that to my advantage then we're
gonna get farther can I run with this no
I can run with this scissors why can't I
wait I really can't I can run with the
scissors so what no huh oh I dropped the
scissors okay well those are lost
forever to the void but maybe in my room
there was more cabinetry in my room
wasn't there nothing there that's not a
book yeah okay huh interesting
okay I'm onto something run from the
tall guy okay again I I don't seem to be
able to get very far from him but I will
try this one time is key okay so these
are all him so these are definitely all
hints whoa
ah a bottle over there watch out demons
I'm gonna open your brain a can opener
yeah yeah give you a lobotomy [ __ ] oh
all right fine
bash out of here deal Eataly B Liddy
anything in the fridge no nothing what's
the point I'm not gonna wash the dishes
washing the dishes seems to be the one
thing that gets me dead all right time
is key choose wisely
all of these they're talking about
something but I don't know what what are
they talking about
cabinets dishes it's all part of a big
plan nope don't do that I don't like
that nope okay so something about time
something about time so these keep
resetting the yeah they all are doing
the same exact song and dance
Emily's outside huh interesting
yes welcome welcome welcome everybody
this is something okay all right okay
so they're all saying five does that
mean something okay
no I don't like that oh [ __ ] okay ye so
the clocks paintings on the wall I've
been trying to use the paintings on the
wall but I haven't been able to see
anything from that because if there's
something that the painting is on the
wall they don't change
but Mayo are you talking about like the
the the the small ones the square ones
it might be might be maybe maybe not
maybe I'm crazy I'm probably definitely
crazy but I think there's something to
this oh there's something to this
alright so I suppose the dishes before
we go there's something here so you must
know you must see the answer to know the
answer if these are hints all right and
if I was choose wisely or fail oh oh oh
oh oh five yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes I need a key card I need two key
card I gotta get hurt
I'm leaving I'm leaving I'm really
really leaving I'm leaving I'm leaving
I'm leaving leaving leaving
can I go home hey Emily hi you want to
play Emily I keep having that same
nightmare huh what say what now - who -
what join me in another delicious shower
[Music]
I don't like this at all
I like this the opposite of what this is
oh I don't have that hole in my house
anymore I don't think that's a good idea
I don't know I don't think any of this
is a good idea hmm
I'm gonna go shower oh it's fine stop
crying oh you just have so much trust
over what you're seeing in front of my
face are you honestly saying that you
you're just okay with everything here
and if I take a shower and I do the
dishes everything's fine
jump-scare list there's no jump-scare
list you're watching this with me you're
watching this with me why do I keep
having that strange dream I don't know
maybe
dum-dum tikka how's it going what's
going on Bob
chicas over there just look down the
whole time I don't think that's a good
idea give it a good spoop I don't know
everything looks normal calm down that
in horror games when everything looks
normal that's when you should be the
most apprehensive I should wash the
dishes before I go sure okay yeah okay
all right then chica can't save us
chica can't save us from this no no no
spoofing poop trust us it's fine now I
don't trust you at all I don't trust you
even a little bit of what I do oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah where's da go da goes
down there but we'll get the dog go in a
second just let me uh let me figure this
out okay all these scary ass dishes
they're just a goddamn nightmare don't I
feel like I should look back once more
before I leave hmm I guess I was wrong
doc I don't know
oh I thought it was over wait okay wait
okay was that like anyone here hey Jimmy
John's Jimmy John's no no oh okay then
all right okay that's just how it's
gonna be all right
all right fine men that's fine it's all
good that's great
okay cool we got some new friends in the
thing all right cool I don't know what's
up with tall guy and I don't know what's
up with statue guy dark applier over
there on the left but that's pretty cool
but the games don't end here that was
the demo for Emily wants to play to the
full game is not out yet it will be out
soon I've got another horror game lined
up for you right now that I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be getting underway so give me
just a second I'm gonna get this game
for you and then we're gonna move right
on because the scoops don't end on
Halloween and then at noon I've got a
little sneak peek for you at noon if you
guys liked space is cool the song by
schmoyoho I wanna I want to just play
you a little snippet just the audio but
at noon a very special video is gonna be
coming out that you guys should
definitely check out here's a little
sneak break a sneak peek of it if you
guys
[Music]
okay
okay anyway that's all you get for now
but at noon that video is coming out so
in 45 minutes I'm gonna keep streaming
all the way up till noon so you guys
don't have to worry about losing out on
scary games and whatnot and that should
be really cool it is it is one of my
favorite things that they've ever done
well for me they've done a ton of other
stuff but I just got to be so I'm so
grateful to schmoyoho for making that
and that's gonna be coming out at noon
so it's gonna be super cool super super
cool so I look forward to that coming
out right like right after this stream
is done but the next game that we got
it's called unbridled [ __ ] or unbridled
horror it's an indie game that I got off
gamejolt I'm loading it up right now and
then I will be getting it underway daily
do did it literally do it it literally
dude it it literally dude hang on all
right let's get the game up and Blau
let's see if that works without breaking
ah ha there we go
okay so unbridled horror I have no idea
what this game is about all I know is
that the game quite possibly is spooky
so let's get into it I'm in control with
the controller oh that's in Russian
anybody hate does anybody speak Russian
in the comments right now that knows
what this says if you do write in the
comments below and hopefully uh
hopefully that will help
oh boy I don't know why it's turned
blood-red that's that's that's not good
that's not good okay so it is not a
controller game like the other one so
I'm gonna do WASD a letter excuse me how
do i I can't move on oh I can jump wait
is it no yeah
turn this off excuse you I don't want to
open the game bar there we go okay oh
there we go
there we go okay we're good all right so
okay ah so I got a flashlight and it's
got ass temporary time thing it's made
in the Unreal Engine if anyone cares
about that sort of stuff I do oh that's
a squall key door those are bloody
handprints hey I wasn't done with the
door there what what what did I lose my
operative arrow just lost my opportunity
to go through the door here we go again
into the spooks she can look like me
chicas looking at me so concerned that
it's loud that's a clunky funk chica why
are you staring at me like that
chicas giving me the weirdest stare
right now that I've ever seen in my life
hang on I have to like I'm gonna take a
small video this cuz it's just super
weird cuz she looks happy but she's okay
so chicas just staring at me right now
and I don't know why she's just like
cheek are you okay she can you okay okay
there's a little tail you're alright pop
you're right
pop okay good girl
what's going on you okay pop oh no hmm
oh she's alright I got into this
anyway so chicas just looking a little
shook maybe she doesn't like me like
screaming in terror she tells sometimes
gets a little worried for me it's okay
Bob good girl good girl
that's a good girl okay I'm fine just a
little more squeeze here and there oh
poor little bump she cares about me
she's like why is master screaming why
is master so skilled normally master is
brave but today no brave aah why why why
why is that in my house why is that in
my house at all and why why why is that
they're locked oh great okay so what do
I do about that
what Oh what am I supposed to be doing I
can't open that yes I can oh there we go
ah okay close that close that Matt yeah
can I open the bottom on there crouch or
something no damn it okay so if there's
got to be something else in here that
allows me to get out right why is there
a bloody handprint on that one I just
don't know all right clunker stonker you
anything to do with this flashlight whoa
oh I guess I'm just non-existent or is
this just actually another hallway is
that wait is this one of those moments
where that's actually the hallway here
or is that completely different no
that's weird
okay well I can't go back why is there a
window here wait that window doesn't
make any sense why is the window on the
interior of that something's weird here
but this is locked so what do I do
Oh goobie alright so there's got to be
something with the handprints right
because there were handprints going up
the wall and then there's handprint
right here
I can't rotate this or anything so
there's got to be something around what
is it though what is it
where are those going alright I'm
pressing use them pretty much everything
I got over here but there's just nothing
to see and I can't go back so what do I
do
someone please tell me what do I do
things don't make sense in this world
and yet I'm lost I can't even open this
drawer that's supposedly looking like
it's important because it's got a
handprint on it
I've got these weird snow painting here
what's going on right there's got to be
something here unless I'm just
absolutely out of my mind huh books
books books books books books books
books books books books books books I
can't climb up here press B to blow I'm
smacking on B I'm really slammed bamming
it and it's really doing nothing for me
so I don't think B to blow is gonna help
anybody here oh well how do you do
picked up house key well it was right by
the door that I needed it okay well
that's awfully convenient alrighty then
okie dokie I don't know what to do about
that okay no no no no I don't know oh no
no no oh hi hello how are you doing ah
good excellent
oh good excellent
ah these are the things that I'm very
happy about sir sir sir no thank you no
thank you no thank you
oh I'm backward goddamnit these goddamn
with quick doors I'm not prepared for it
I just want to take my time on my doors
okay
well I'm back you ah music that's a
choice okay I got an app full I got an
Apple good for me what is that gonna do
for me is that good for me I don't know
am I just gonna be stuck in a loop is
this all I'm doing is I'm stuck in a
loop [ __ ] not my fault that didn't scare
me at all
Boop Amon is snoot you guys have the
worst advice I'm not gonna take him out
to dinner I'm not gonna kiss him I'm not
gonna poop him on his smooth not gonna
do any of those things cuz they're
terrible ideas and you guys have
terrible advice was that always there I
don't feel like those were always there
before oh good bottle of blood on the
pneuma is that ladawna numb middle
medkit Oh
good good gray gray yeah gray kill it
with fire
finally some sensible advice out of you
guys some sensible honest true advice
kill it with fire I've never heard such
genius before locked no no make him do
the dishes now there's a punishment
worth I know now that's a punishment
worth doing doing the dishes over and
over and I'll make him shower - I'll
make him use lots of soap in his shower
oh this is not what did what was it this
is new I don't know what this is and why
this is here oh that's bad that's very
clearly bad that a rocking ship rocking
by itself is very clearly bad I like it
I don't like it at all okay fine then
thank you oh all right okay cool all
right cool great okay okay fine we're
fine we're fine everything's fine I'm
panicking over nothing
okay alright so this is now the same but
it's at our there's no door
why is there no door why you would you
not have a door oh I don't know I don't
like no no no no I don't like that no
don't like that all right everything's
fine it was all apparently a dream I
guess
little skittery scattery bastard Crypt
crawling all over the floor friggin
[ __ ] yeah yeah okay what is what Oh
sparking okay well I guess I'm back here
again now aren't I so do I just gotta go
through the loop again I bet I do
sound of a biscuit son of a biscuit
let's keep going I just I guess it burn
burn everything to the ground okay
that's that's pretty good run brave one
run don't think I'm showcasing myself
and being very brave right now but thank
you all the books have been scattered
about it's all fine these ghosts are
they pull the chair out for me oh I'm so
glad about that thank you very much
thank you you are so incredibly nice to
me whoo that that that is the Pooh pious
toilet I've ever seen in my entire life
it's like the Hulk was in here and had a
bad time oh the Jolly Green Giant wasn't
so jolly in here ah should I take a
shower in this water
I don't know what that's all about they
don't like it
excuse me I'm pooping this ain't they
come in poop time I'm busy I'm very
preoccupied ear I'm having an ordeal
nope
no I don't want that no don't no none of
that no I'm like I said pooping gonna be
in here for a bit you stay out there
I'll be in there okay you stay there
I'll be there you stay here you stay
there and be here all right cool
goddamn poop demons up in this place the
walls will ooze green all right that's
just silly that barely scared me you
guys are
I thought these ghosts were more polite
than that okay
these goddamn poop demons think that
they're gonna scare me the answer is a
solid maybe
oh good grandma the ghost of Grandma
still I can't I'm not moving I'm not
moving that nope used to be different
someone's been around here yeah no
kidding this didn't used to be upside
down that couch wasn't topsy-turvy and
grandmas on the other side no grandma
grandma Emma okay all right grandma you
stay you stay good
yiii okay it was grandma all along I
would not be surprised at that idea okay
everything seems to be fine
[Music]
well that loop was uneventful Oh
can't move oh it crashed okay is that
the end
oh you can't end it like that oh come on
oh don't do that
gosh darn it oh god damn it don't do
that oh don't do that
oh god damn it
Oh Frick that was such a good game but
that was a demo of that game that was
called unbridled horror and damn it that
was so good oh man I'm disappointed but
I've got more game for you here I'm not
I'm not over yet I've got more ready
just in case those ones went a little
shorter than I imagined
if you guys remember you remember a game
that started a little thing called be to
blow and the sequel of this game came
out about two years ago and I always
meant to get to it and I played the demo
I did play the demo of it but I never
actually played the full game now think
back to where B tableau first came from
dungeon nightmares and dungeon
nightmares - is here and it's been here
for a long time and I always meant to
get to it and this one of the other
reasons why I like live streams and
being able to have more time to do this
and not worrying about like recording
than editing and then uploading when I
can do it all in one we can just shift
gears and go straight in to dungeon
nightmares - which is exactly what we're
gonna be doing now III don't know how
much different it's gonna be from the
demo but dungeon nightmares was so
terrifying hey night terrors pav Warnock
turnus I get those all the time the
disorder of sleep characterized by a
dream of Terramax finding dimensions far
worse than a typical nightmare yeah I
suppose the problem with night terrors
and what makes them scary
let's see this burger like blam oh I got
no candles I can't be to blow and I have
no candles water baby
[Music]
you walk into a dungeon that's
terrifying and the first book you come
across is the horrifying tale of water
that why isn't moving oh I don't know oh
it's very creepy yeah that was that was
exactly what I was gonna say yeah that's
that's very creepy not sure what to do
with it but you come across a book
that's water babies and a world of girls
what the hell is going on here this is
used for drinking is used for drinking
it can't be blood who'd have thought it
was blood how do I know it's blood just
cuz there's blood in it doesn't mean
that people drank from it making a lot
of assumptions here and they don't like
it present m4 map I've got a map oh
that's not cool oh yeah this is
definitely different than the demo that
I played and I remember nothing I
remember absolutely nothing about this
game what do we got here a little pretty
pocketbook oh it's upside down there we
go January 20 2008 I will end this
tonight even if it means killing myself
e Fitzpatrick
okay e Fitzpatrick just don't drag me
into your plans no idea what to do with
a useless bits of old metal but god
damnit what happened to my treasure
collecting that was my favorite part
this was used for drinking blood what
about this who's this body used for
drinking blood oh boy
oh no the chair the terrifying
horrifying chair alright that's your way
to go back here nah it's all a dead end
okay there's got to be some candles here
somewhere somewhere in this horrifying
place is exactly what we need oh yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah okay all
right I thought that was bad
oh yeah that's right that you can't
sprint forever I forgot about that I
forgot about that
oh good blood on the walls oh I forgot
about that
oh that's not good okay that's fine no I
know it's no bueno but we'll get to it
we'll get through this together with the
power of love and friendship and and
love also love lots of love we'll get
through this
ah no we won't cuz we'll reach a goddamn
dead end oh my god are you kidding me
Jesus please be nothing nothing okay
yeah I will be playing evil within -
yeah that is next on my list of stuff to
play I will be doing a full playthrough
of that as well and yeah it'll be good
okay so far so nothing which is good I'd
rather have nothing than a whole lot of
something but so far so nothing which is
good I guess it's waiting for me to get
a candle or it's waiting for me to
actually like make some progress in this
game whereas right now I'm just being a
big old idiot and not getting anywhere
but nonetheless trying my best here
getting pretty far if I could just do
what I need to do
blood for Gabby's skulls roasting on an
open fire oh good a chest oh good open
this up do I get treasure nothing
absolutely dick diddly I get nothing
oh god I can't even take the Bulls
anymore imported from China Oh what do I
care I don't want to know what's inside
why don't you wanna know what's inside
oh wait
I made it I made it I made it out
what do you thought that I would have
made it out oh [ __ ] I made it out oh
there was a candle to back but it's okay
cuz I made it out of the first area oh
that's right in the demo you were
dropped into the game right away oooh
October 31st 11:30 6:00 a.m. which is
weird because that's the exact time that
it is now
someone's here boy all right so we got
figure out okay but why though uh-huh
okay all right then that's cool but why
though it's just uh it's just a shower
well I don't know about that because
last time I needed a shower I needed a
shower a great deal no matter how spooky
and scary the things going on around
here were oh yeah I remember you I don't
remember that okay well that's that's
plenty terrifying it's a golden bear
must be that's it Fred boys 308 is not
my room I you don't know that you don't
know that at all
306 is not my room 305 is not my room
there's a giant mattress in the hallway
I need the key okay I can't answer right
now all righty then
okay there's an elevator at the end of
this hall I'm assuming that I got a drop
back down into the dungeon and just kind
of hope for the best here but I don't
know if I can do it right away
I can do it right away okay well good
I'll back in I go back down I go okay
all right great
claustrophobic yeah no joke slam all
those doors I just got to wake up
everybody in the hallway like hey did
you know it's terrifying out here
hey donk donk excuse me it's awful you
want to help me maybe no okay I see all
right
run your what I like that level of that
level was nice oh now this level this is
my level explore the basement for clues
what kind of basement is is why did I
need to go into a basement in the first
place I should look around for clues
about this place maybe I should but also
maybe I should not cuz that's that's
like what I want I guess what I want
doesn't matter
there's a room over here
Oh oh good more skulls perfect love it
love it love it love it love it love it
love it what is this building I don't
know what this building is I have no
idea what this building is this building
is just super weird and bizarre and I'm
good what am I going in a goddamn circle
Here I am
wow I just went in a goddamn circle
because I picked the wrong damn
direction okay I saved my stamina gotta
remember to be to blow when I got the
opportunity to be the blow hello hello
oh okay that's fine this corpse is in
the basement of the building that I live
in apparently totally normal
run I'm trying to run you can't run that
hard okay I'm trying my best
blow the what blow the water I have no
idea what you just said it what game is
this this is dungeon nightmares too
so whereas dungeon nightmares one was a
thing and then the demo for dungeon
nightmares came out and then I had never
really got around to playing dungeon
nightmares the full game now I finally
have and I'm eagerly awaiting to see
what kind of bony bony bony bony Bonino
bony Pony pony pony pony pony you're
moving nothing special about this
skeleton it dick they're very very
clearly something special about that
moving skeleton about that skeleton that
moves get up and walks around
[Music]
okay okay
scissors there's a tooth stuck in this
one great okay what do we got here 1993
the trick to survive is to keep moving
and the hood thanks om HUD okay all
right that's an option oh it's a dead
end
great okay interesting choice you made
there okay that skeletons a little weird
huh anything special about this one how
does it stay upright how why is it
moving why isn't bad the question that
you're asking everybody why is it that
the question why do you why do you mean
whines of moving the rose in the ring
okay I'm out of here I don't know why
it's no bow oh okay there's no Bower
okay all right then I guess I'll go back
and go the other way okay hello
no okay all right that's how we're gonna
be that's how we're gonna play this game
the flat iron for a farting the first
day of my visit went great today I was
told tomorrow would be even better can't
wait this is to what this lovely
basement is perfectly lovely basement
where's the goddamn switch for power
I've been where is the switch for power
I've been everywhere I haven't seen a
switch have I did you guys see a switch
did anybody out there see a switch
because I thought I didn't see no switch
and yet it's saying I saw switches and I
definitely did not maybe in this room
over here and I didn't look close enough
it would be glowing it would have like a
big glowing thing on it yeah you guys
didn't you guys didn't the power was in
you all along I appreciate the
confidence boost and I know I'm a no
wonderful beautiful shining light in the
darkness but it doesn't help me get
power to the goddamn thing
the famous pipes care Thank You yes I'm
aware of the famous pipes care okay I
don't think there's gonna be any
monsters on the way back so I think this
is gonna be near the skeleton you
knocked over maybe beat boney I don't
think it's be too bony at all I don't
think be too bony you missed a room I
did oh I did oh you were right I did I
did miss a room okay so back this way
there's a room that I missed ah
and I'm gonna be to blow all up in that
room you are correct you are absolutely
correct smart person use smart person
that's a smart person handsome too
beautiful and smart
hello Jess yes please give me treasures
oh the little girl left her teddy behind
again maybe she doesn't like it no room
three one three key found find the exit
Oh a candle well let me just light this
bad boy up shebang and then I've got my
B to blow charged up you can't see it
right now but if you look behind the me
here right here B to blow baby B to blow
I'm gonna let that stay there because
[Music]
okay all right all right everything's
fine
didn't scare me at all there's the
switch all right got power going
everything's good we're happy I'm happy
you're happy let's get out of here let's
beat up below this place this place can
be to blow itself I know it didn't scare
me and anyone that says otherwise is
just being a goof I didn't even get to
be Tablo I think actually I did meet
what do you say about myself what did
you say about my shelf nope no don't
know not no not a thing not a thing nope
I'm gonna get to the exit perfectly
organ arey everything's great
that was quite a vertical I had and we
Gucci oh it it's all Gucci baby okay
alright then good great okay we did that
great good golly gosh we got that under
way okay so we got that we're waking up
again it looks like grumpy cat who woke
up why am I still here I don't know why
are you still here
why do you need can I say the national
anthem again you have the key to room
three one three
okay well let's go see what's in room
three one three can I go take a shower
it's just a shower can't really see
myself it not right now one's not a good
time to shower if anything Emily wants
to play Tommy it's a shower when you
need a shower how you doing buddy the
seat feels warm the first thing I do
when I go to a chair is check the ass
part for warmth that's what I always
look for in my chairs that I observe I
really just like to get in there give it
a go
like sniff it you know just to see if I
recognize the person that was once there
here let me get a girl sniff of that
chair here come on bring that chair over
to me oh yeah
that's warm all right let me get a good
look at that boy okay three one three
where would three one three be okay
alright 309 three times three one two
one one two this is three one three
I shouldn't disturb them are you talking
about these bars are you talking about
three one three from three one two is
locked okay what about this one do I see
something Oh
oh I don't don't know no don't know I
don't for the for the record I don't I
want to be very clear you think I see
something the answer is no I obviously
don't that stupid and you're an idiot if
you stink you see something and you're
dumb just the no brain in you just like
me all right three one three Pennywise
don't do it please
I'm too young penny wise I hate
everything about this and the worst part
is you guys have to come in with me
there's no jump-scare list there's no
looking away oh that's a big bear oh
there's a big bear well how big bear I
feel creeped out just by looking at it
talking about is it the blood here let
me get a go sniff of the butt part yeah
okay all right oh yeah that's warm oh
yeah your your butt's warm buddy that
creeps me out
huh man right about that all right come
here something is blocking the door on
the other side well what could it be is
it warm I don't know good old sip of
that
jeez
all righty then why did I go on here oh
that's awful that's the worst thing I've
ever heard in my entire life oh that's
that's awful that is literally the worst
you don't like that in any capacity all
right well my nightmares are here and I
love them so wait let me see I better
not you know you might be right about
that one you might be right
why is this one a staff room staff you
don't have the key to this staff room in
there no I can't get to it okay yeah
okay we just I don't want to turn around
I don't trust you guys I don't trust you
I don't trust myself I don't trust
anything that's happening no I don't
like that no I don't like that no I
don't like that at all
no that's the opposite of what I like I
shouldn't disturb them you're right
about that you are right 100% about that
all right just enough time to go down
here and then at noon that the new song
drops so check that out it's it's coming
out as a video it's got a whole music
video proponent to it you guys are gonna
love it so I'm gonna just go down here
for another few minutes get scared a
little bit more and then we've got a
awesome song to try to cheer us back up
on this horrible Halloween this is where
I started yeah no Joe I don't like that
one like jump off there can I jump can I
jump off there No
[Music]
maybe someday wait till you get off the
elevator find another key and exit great
you know what hmm the walls have changed
ah weird there has to be more Keys past
the there be keep an eye out for secret
walls and floors floors 5 6 get that
crucifix okay all right that's weird but
alright Blanc Blanc Blanc Blanc want
want want gimme scare me scare me you
don't scare me none of you do captain
courageous oh that's an eye that's
wonderful I love that the young fur
traders bizarre it sees what you cannot
okay ominous I like it very ominous
alright let's see ooh I don't trust that
at all nope don't trust that not gonna
go that way
peculiar in that that's horrible
it's frying air no guillotine over my
head this time and candles sure are
sparse around here there's a crack on
the right side oh god is that maggots
whoa sorry I don't want to keep looking
at the maggots you know what I don't
either okay secret room they're not
really secret when there's a ton of
these just strewn about feels colder
than touch yeah I wonder why oh it's a
skull yeah you didn't give me that time
I know what you're up to I know what
you're on about what's this whoa okay
alright that's Wow I've seen them okay
well that's
ow
what the hell might lose that what is
the owl painting the painting of oof
goodness gracious no need to do that to
me the tapestry room right okay this one
nah this is a dead end okay dad nd er no
switches that I saw no switches that I
saw moving on all right goodness
gracious this game is spooky alright yo
yo yo
well game is this is dungeon nightmares
- done should have blown it yeah I
should have okay it looks really old I
don't know if I've ever seen a really
young skeleton but I'm pretty sure the
my powers of observation in this game
are just a little bit above average I am
just the world's greatest detective up
in here oh my god like a gig I don't I
have no idea what to do about that oh my
god [ __ ] you you [ __ ] [ __ ] where
am i I'm going down a dead-end I'm dead
okay well this has been a fun run what
do i do what do i do what do i do god
that's not nice okay that's not nice at
all screw yourself and your squeaking
squeaks won't embrace it you know what I
think I won't I think I'd rather not do
that can I get my stamina back please
can I run at some point would be great
but good screaming could stop at any mom
that I'd be wonderful okay I think it's
getting farther away oh did I oh no I
didn't know okay we're good good god is
that screaming ever gonna stop to stop
go away each I get it yeah there's a
zombie chasing me through the halls but
really no need for all of this there we
go fading down okay here we go
don't like that at all it's filled with
old rags great good for me
buh buh knee what bony bony oh it's bony
ain't it
Oh bony see something bony bony Pony
boat okay so I haven't found the key yet
there's another room over here to the
left just before this one I'm almost out
of time but I can do oh there's no room
here okay
ah damn it I missed someplace on the way
back
all right why did you do that why did
you do that
why boney I can't believe bone easier
that's amazing boney I love boney bomi's
glades Oh
boney woulda bonerific boner fricken
boney alright so this game is dungeon
nightmares and it's awesome but
unfortunately I just ran out of stamina
and I just ran out of time it is it is
almost noon noon is in one minute and I
want you guys to know there is an
awesome video coming out at noon made by
schmoyoho if you guys haven't seen if
you guys haven't seen space is so cool I
want to give you a little preview of it
right here
[Music]
okay
okay so that video just released I
believe it just released on my channel
right now and I'm ending the stream
right here thank you everybody so much
for watching that song is actually about
mostly about joy of creation and and a
few other games and a few other
surprises that you're gonna see the
video just got released everybody please
go see that give it a like and go
subscribe to schmoyoho because they made
it they did all the work on it and they
are absolutely incredible check it out
on my channel that just came out fly
like a butterfly Marga bar song if I
remix by schmoyoho thank you everybody
so much for watching happy Halloween and
get ready for more of these live streams
whenever I'm able to do them I'm hoping
to do them very often for a couple hours
like every every day ideally but it's
not gonna be every day life gets in the
way like that and there's always other
projects that I want to work on but in
the end more gaming stuff for that so
check it out give a like for schmoyoho
share it around it's super cool thank
you again everybody so much for being
here and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye bye bye guys bye bye
bye bye bye